we're here with the man that crushed the
candidates
not the best day for you but on the
other hand huge news
what are your feelings now that you're
going to be playing ding loretta instead
of magnus carlsen
yeah quite some news uh you know i'm
not privileged not supposed to speak you
know on behalf of the chess community
yes i'll just
speak on behalf of myself it
yeah personally for me was of course
quite disappointing
uh and just uh quite sad and
uh it's not about like the human
decision it's completely understandable
and of course i respect it uh because
first of all uh
uh me like and magnus like we have some
quite good relationships and we know we
shower like for i would say 20 years or
something
so
i
can imagine it was quite a painful
decision for him as well
but i also feel like maybe maybe he felt
himself more or less like i would say
hostage of this whole situation yes so
he
[Music]
probably yes he obliged to
supposedly he obliged to to defend the
title every time and uh perhaps it's
it's a huge pressure yes out of my uh
quite small comparing to him experience
of the title matches it's uh it could be
not not great but uh i mean also like
candidates yeah despite the result it's
very tough right
so
of course
it's quite disappointing for me but uh
also i guess it could be you know quite
some harm which could be down to the
chest by this decision but i mean once
again i'm
i'm not in position to to judge
and
i must say that magnus was is and
probably will be
one of the greatest chess ambassadors
you know regardless his decision
talk to us a little bit about the
upcoming match i mean you're playing a
completely different player you're not
going to be playing the number one
player in the world in your personal
opinion does it host does it hold the
same value
well
i think so because
it's uh
more or less you know it's it's the same
yeah it's uh it's a title match
and uh
once again i have
as i have said before for many times uh
you know i relate things chess quality
is like quite high
i wouldn't say like he's
like
anything quicker like overall in chess
wise than magnus okay magnus is
a tremendous sportsman and this uh
however makes
makes a difference but yeah chess wise
dink is just completely outstanding
player absolutely it's going to be a
tough match as we see there your match
against dingley reigns scheduled for
next year it's going to be a tough one
we wish you the best of luck on this
tournament and of course on the match
thank you thank you guys back to the
studio one game remaining thank you
yan for
sharing